I think of you as a researcher but
you've also been
uh doing research in the field yeah
field work the field work the chain
could all over
yeah
how did you get uh what's the the short
and the long story of how you got into
sex work how did I get into sex work
well the I mean there's a whole like
childhood thing where I was
conservatively homeschooled uh do you
want to actually talk about your
childhood I think it's interesting
because you also worked at a factory
it's like your childhood is really
fascinating uh and difficult uh
traumatic so um and you've written about
it
there's a lot of ways we can talk about
it but maybe
what are the things you remember
the good and the bad of your childhood
of your maybe interaction with your
father
yeah my dad probably has narcissistic
personality disorder and so it was very
centered on very controlling childhood
uh immensely so
um we were homeschooled and pretty
isolated from the outside world like we
didn't know anybody else who wasn't
homeschooled we went through a program
called Growing Kids God's way which was
very is like the kind of program where
you're not supposed to pick up babies
when they cry to train them that they
can't manipulate the parents because
like baby crying was viewed as like uh
you're teaching them from an early age
that they're allowed to make the parents
do what the kids want yeah and are very
against this philosophy so you know that
combined with a narcissistic personality
disorder dad was pretty rough uh so
controlling super controlling yeah and
developing and feeding the self-critical
aspect of your brain yeah very much it
was you know I was like lazy but I was
never going to accomplish anything in
life it's gonna move out of the house
and realize how good I had it at home
you know the classic stuff uh he was
very like logical and smart though and
so he'd also like teach us logic stuff I
remember some of my earliest memories or
him like giving me basic logic puzzles
like the dog has three legs you know how
many dogs the four legs and I I would
mess up and
but he was he was a evangelist basically
a Christian evangelist so we like Bible
study five nights a week I memorized I
think 800 verses of the Bible by the
time before I became an adult
um
yeah and it was very patriarchal also so
I was expected to go up and become a
housewife basically they're like oh you
can go to college to meet a man and also
to get a little bit of education so you
can homeschool your own kids like we
were explicitly told that women were
subordinate to men
um in regards to like making decisions
when you're married our pastor's
daughter was not allowed to leave home
because she would be outside of the
authority of a man so when she got
married she was allowed to leave because
she was never allowed to live in a house
where she was not uh under a hierarchy
this is like the kind of culture that
that we live so there's a hierarchy and
uh there's a gender aspect to the
hierarchy there's men at the top of that
hierarchy men at the top
okay but you're on psychology your own
mind
um so most of that self-critical brain
is bad right it was confusing because he
told me that I was smart but also that I
would fail
but I I I'm not smart enough right or
like smart but not smart enough smart
but like not virtuous or something okay
so okay right there's always a flaw yeah
there's always a flaw I think a lot of
it was a lot of the the [__] upness of
my brain came from feeling like I didn't
have the authority to think because it
was so like carefully like suppressed
like the my ability to like Express or
have any sort of power was just
absolutely annihilated like systemically
like psychologically they would do like
psychological torture mechanisms to make
sure that like I wasn't actually
thinking on my own or like being able to
deviate from anything anybody ever told
me to the degree that it's still
ingrained in me like I once was a friend
we were traveling and he wanted me to
hop a Turn Style it was like very late
at night the train was here and I could
not physically force myself to do it
like he was like yelling me like come on
do it like like no but I was trying so
hard to make my body across the line and
it was just it's like embedded in my
physical being to like be unable to do
stuff like that which is really annoying
that you're not free to take action in
this world yeah
so it's that that was I think the most
annoying part of the my upbringing
would you classify it as like suffering
at the time yeah definitely well it's
confusing because like when when I was a
child it was it was just painful in the
sense that like things suck but it was
placed in a meaning framework right like
it is good it is virtuous to submit to
your parents and do what they want if
they tell you to say goodbye to your
best friend forever and ever talk to
them again you go do that without
complaining and so like I would go do
something like that and I would like it
would suck it really was like concretely
painful but it was also placed in this
narrative where I was like fulfilling
some sort of Greater purpose sure uh and
so so it's very confusing to refer to it
as suffering because there's so many
painful things we do today that are
placed in The Narrative of a greater
purpose that like I think I would agree
with like I go get a medical procedure
done that sucks but I'm like ah this is
helping me in the long run but like say
if I got abducted to an alien planet and
they're like by the way all of those
medical procedures you got done like you
didn't have to get them done those are
totally unnecessary then I might get
really upset about it yeah I wouldn't
trust those aliens though because they
probably want to do different messes
I saw I saw some a a thumbnail for a
video that I'm proud of myself for not
clicking on about a man who's claimed
that he had sex with aliens
and I was like for not clicking on that
because I was wondering because because
that I would probably watch it for like
20 minutes and then I should be doing
work oh I see so like I and I I and I'm
actually happy because I get to imagine
what it all the different possibilities
that could have been for that man just
had like a really high like resting
happiness State yes yeah it's probably
like a mushroom State yeah wow do you do
mushrooms I've done mushrooms before it
was very awesome
but like more intensely awesome
but but like like because I was just
looking at nature it makes nature even
more beautiful I think but it's already
it's already pretty beautiful I haven't
done MDMA
um
how people say that I I should it's very
nice yeah yeah anyway
um but I'm already yeah what did you
call it resting happiness day yeah
harvesting happening happiness
yeah that's a good that's a good way to
describe it but it's not like some of
it's genetic that you're able to notice
the beauty in the world and some of it
is practiced where you realize focusing
on the negative things in life
like unproductively is uh
it's it just doesn't help your mind
flourish so like you just notice that
and it's like
I mean I think people with like
depression uh learn that or like
probably with trauma too is like there's
certain triggers like if you're if you
suffer from depression you have to kind
of consciously know there's going to be
triggers that will expire like force you
to spiral down and so just avoid those
triggers some people have that with diet
with food and so on and so I just don't
like whenever there's uh shitty things
happening or Shady people
unless I can help on this unless I can
do somehow hope like what why focus on
it yeah anyway uh
back to you upbringing what uh
what was the Journey of escaping that
um I well I left home got kind of early
um because my my dad and I were not
getting along by the time I was a
teenager
um but I still Christian for a while and
I lost my faith after I think I moved it
away and I started having friends that
weren't religious or like weren't raised
in the super conservative environment
that I came from and I think uh I this
was not conscious at the time this was
my hindsight story but I believe that
like being exposed to a culture in which
I had the capacity to believe like
allowed my brain to actually seriously
consider the thought that maybe all of
this stuff was untrue that I'd been
taught like six thousand year old Earth
and evolution is a lie you know
macroevolution and all of this stuff uh
because like when you're when you're in
immersed in an environment like that I
don't think you actually have a choice
like your brain has to believe these
things because this is a survival thing
like if you believe this you'll be com
like if you believe the wrong thing
you'll be totally cast out even if
they're not gonna cast you out you're
going to be cast out in like communion
with others because we're always told
that you can't like trust non-believers
really they don't have a moral compass
they're going to screw you over and so
I'm like oh I can't beat that like
everybody's gonna Outcast me internally
yeah so anyway I wasn't I don't think I
actually had the capacity to seriously
question my faith even though I thought
that I was questioning it quite hard
until I got into an environment where it
was safe to do so and once I started
being able to make friends who were not
religious I'm like oh if I lose my faith
I'm still going to have some sort of
community
um and then at that time I went through
some questioning and then I lost my
faith and
so in that given your friends giving you
a situation you have you you now have
the freedom to think essentially or at
least the ability to think of something
that was acceptable in the new culture
yeah
without
I mean is there a danger of like
adopting the beliefs of the new culture
so like there's some aspect of just
being able to think freely which you
weren't able to do when you were growing
up just to think like look at the world
and wonder how it works that kind of
thing but I mean you wear it within
certain boundaries like there's certain
basic assumptions
and as long as you're following those
basic assumptions which is to be fair
it's like kind of what we're doing now
like we have I have I gone and done the
personal research that like evolution is
the thing that's going on have I looked
at like the age of the stones no I
haven't I'm trusting other people yeah
uh which I think is like a fair choice
to make given where I'm at right now but
you're also assuming like
there's causality in the universe time
is real yeah that like that first of all
the thing that your senses are
perceiving is real
you're assuming a lot of things
the assumptions you're making like as
opposed to not making those assumptions
at all that you have to assume something
and I did it's very suspicious right
that I went out of this very
conservative culture and now I well I
guess I don't believe things that are
super in line with the current culture I
think this is why I feel a little bit
safer right now because like when I was
Christian I believe generally Christian
things but now I believe a bunch of
things that like people really hate like
I get canceled online all the time I'm
like okay this is a sign that maybe
you're thinking independently if you're
like able to think things that are
completely at odds with the people
around you and and to be fair this is a
little bit easier to do when it's like
General culture but it's much harder to
do with your peer group like the people
that you trust your friends the people
whose opinions you respect like
disagreeing with those people is very
difficult and I'm not very good at it
yeah I do think that if you establish
yourself as a person who can be trusted
and is a good human being you have a lot
more freedom
to then explore ideas that are different
from your peer group so like those seem
if you separate the space of ideas
versus some kind of like deeper sense of
what this person is
like that that this they're an
interesting and trustworthy and good
human being well like do you're somebody
that you respect who you consider
significantly smarter than you and can
you imagine believing an idea that
you've heard them talk really
disdainfully about like how would you
feel coming to me like I believe this
thing that you find to be
yeah I do all the time oh yeah yeah
maybe braver than me
and Jamaica I support doing this like I
try to do this but I think like like
subconsciously I noticed that I'm I
don't do it as much and so I'm
suspicious of myself I'm like oh I
wonder if I'm hiding to myself like
actual curiosity about things that might
deviate from my peer group because I
noticed that I'm not actually deviating
with them as much as I do with the
outside world yeah since Jimmy like
because I do see most people I interact
with are smarter than me but I also have
this intuitive feeling that uh dumb
people which I consider myself being
have wisdom
so like in the disagreement actually I
also believe in the power of
conversation and in the tension of this
agreement so I think I even just
disagreeing from a place
from a good place from from a place of
like love and respect for each other I
think I just believe in that so it's not
like individuals you're disagreeing
you're like working towards arriving at
some deeper truth together right even if
the other person is is uh
is smarter maybe that's maybe that's how
I justify for myself I just I'm also a
fan of conversations because like I've
seen just listening to conversations
it seems like a great conversation more
emerges from it than the sum of its
parts right like somehow two people
together can do
like that dance of ideas can somehow
create
um create a cool thing by the way I
enjoyed I saw a video of you dancing
at a bar drunk
it wasn't the bar drunk it didn't look
drunk but just the dancing it was like
ballroom dancing type of thing I was
like yeah something like that I've been
doing a bit of Tango dancing I like it
Argentine I
I like stuff with the body in general
like uh like wrestling or combat like
usually when there's a tension you have
to understand the mechanics of how two
bodies move when they're in conflict and
dancing is
similar like you have to do like rapid
thinking also like rapid intuitive
physical thinking and that's my favorite
kind of thing like a lot of exercise is
really boring to me because you can just
do it while your brain's off but
something like ballroom dancing or
Fusion dancing like you have to
constantly be like figuring out like
it's a rapid puzzle and that's so
beautiful what's Fusion dancing that's
the video that's the effusion dancing is
like if you have any sort of dance
background you can come and you just
kind of mix those together speaking of
like people like ballet with people
doing ballroom with people doing Blues
cool and then there's an interesting
dynamic because there's I don't know
maybe you can correct me but there's uh
that's very meta there's usually a lead
and a follow
I guess most dances have that yeah yeah
and so that but both have a different
like you both have to be quite sensitive
to the other human being but in a
different way
yeah it's interesting yes so I like both
that there is that definitive role
but also
like it's not somehow that one is better
than the other there's an interesting
tension between the two yeah yeah it's
good because it's like a basic rule set
that allows for a ton of expression I've
recently started to experience
experiment with like reverse bleeding
it's not like back leading it's like I
don't know like sometimes I was like
what I'm typically following I'll like
occasionally throw in a little lead here
and there but don't but don't you kind
of all oh I see but don't you hit hint
at a lead when you're following
I can't don't you just by the Dynamics
of your movement you're not perfectly
following I mean because there is like
the lead is listening to your body right
yeah so like
you're kind of both figuring out what
you do next that's true I'm a very good
follow though okay so I'm like I'm like
I'm an invisible father you do a move
it's like a oh interesting I'm not good
at Tech I didn't know those existed like
a perfect father
I really I do I'm I'm not great at
technique and sometimes I'll fall over
but like with The Following part I'm
very good at it do you enjoy yeah yeah
it's really nice if it's again like it's
a very fast physical puzzle you have to
solve it's like typing I really like
typing so I was inquiring about your
keyboard earlier why do you like typing
because it's like the very fast like the
really rapid response what's the
reaction time I like things that like
have very fast reaction times like games
like that
but typing is not a reaction or is it
the brain generating words and then
you're like cause typing a reaction okay
The Sensation that I get when I am
typing is the kind of thing that I'm
trying to point out so maybe maybe a
reaction time isn't the quite I don't
know what the term is but whatever that
thing is like the thing where you have
to like look at a word and then
communicate it into your fingers yeah
it feels like dancing like you're
responding you're responding to your
brain your fingers are doing the
responding to the brain to generate the
words making your body do what your
brain wants it to do but like fast and
precisely oh then you might not like
this Kinesis keyboard because it makes
the it makes it easier to do that you
probably like the struggle right no you
well I mean it that it looks hard
because you have it looks like it's high
depression on the keys no it's well oh I
see yes more than more than like a
laptop keyboard but like
that you don't have to one of the the
main things is you don't have to move
your fingers at all
So like
um so like for example a lot of people
that I think they have a backspace up in
the top right corner yeah so if you have
to make mistakes which is like
I mean that's like so metaphorical like
every mistake you have to like really
hurt yourself for because you have to
like stretch for the backspace this
is like a lot of your perspectives yeah
no uh
yeah I don't and I see it as as a good
thing it's a good like a
a romantic element permeates my
interpretation of the world yes but you
uh you left home early
um
how did you end up working at a factory
well I tried to go to college but failed
couldn't afford it
did you like it
I remember it just being really slow I
remember being shocked that the teachers
didn't care like I was used to
homeschooling yeah and and where I don't
know like educate it just like it meant
something they felt like the people
around me that were teaching me because
we had like a mom's group also like
directly cared about what I was learning
and I would be able to ask questions and
they would like really respond to mom's
group and it was like homeschooling
groups there were a bunch of moms who
are homeschooling their kids get
together
and then teach each other's kids
oh cool yeah and they have different
like interests and capabilities and so
on and they kind of and sometimes if
some of the kids are really good at
something you have like the older kids
teaching the other ones too so it's very
like everybody kind of figures out what
they're good at and they should share
that skill set with everybody else which
I think was a pretty great setup
honestly I think my childhood kind of
sucked in a lot of ways but
homeschooling was excellent for me
mainly because it just had so much free
time like I was just did like two to
three hours of school and then did
whatever the [__] I wanted for the rest
of the day and I got to actually pursue
skills that are still useful for me to
this day so
even in that constrained environment
like I wrote I read fantasy books and I
wrote so much and now I'm now I'm
writing a lot from my blog so what kind
of fantasy books like sci-fi type stuff
um like classic like I read
um like Mercedes Lackey and uh the ee
Knight and
um ursulaquin and I don't know any of
this what is this what is it is like a
romantic thing is it like is it romance
it's all the fantasy books like dragons
oh dragons
you didn't mention Tolkien for the
fantasy I read I read Tolkien okay yeah
all right well it's beautiful so you you
uh throw all the dragons
uh how did you end up in effect did you
try school yeah yeah try school had to
drop off a couple months so then I was
like well I'm poor and uh I was I was
trying to take any job I was like
applying for sewer jobs and then I got a
factory I'm like because my parents know
no financial help at all they're like
you pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps you know
so anyway I went to work at a factory
and that sucks ass do not recommend we
had to work up wake up like 4 a.m you
know work on weekends too
fluorescent lights it was terrible and
so I did that for about a year and I was
like this is I was trying to grip my
teeth and be like this is my life right
that I didn't have high expectations for
my life I was just like I thought like
if you get a job where you don't have to
be on your feet all the time that's that
you're living a good life but and then I
got another job briefly as a
photographer and then they fired me I
think I was 19 at the time
fired you for like I was just I was just
too young the end really really bad at
interacting with people in the outside
world like I was pretty well socialized
as a homeschooler with other
homeschoolers but in the outside world
especially with all of the like
hierarchy submissions stuff beaten into
me like literally beaten into me it was
very difficult for me to interact with
other people who were like older than me
or had any sort of confidence at all so
they hired me to do like photography for
people and then I was rapidly turned out
that I was bad at this and so they fired
me but at that point I'd left my factory
job I'm like I can't go back to the
factory so I tried I had some savings
and I slept on Friends couches and I
tried various self-employment stuff I'm
like maybe I can do product photography
or
something but no it's Idaho you know
nothing and if you're like a 19 year old
no experience in the outside world at
all it was really difficult and so I had
a friend recommend that I try being
humming a cam girl so that's how it
started what's what what is uh what is
Cami what is being a cam girl Kimmy is
like you talk to the camera live on the
computer like you live streams kind of
like twitch and then people are typing
in the chat like huh do this stuff and
then the people can tip you money and
then you can do things in response like
oh if you took me 100 tokens you know
I'll take my shirt off or something like
that and like what's the what site were
you using at that time my free camps my
free cams is that a popular site that's
pretty popular okay and how did
um what were the next steps like did you
enjoy it
oh well it was the first time I had
actual control over my life
and I made like actual real money and so
I just exploded into it I thought about
it non-stop I was streaming all the time
I was like coming with like new creative
things and the thing is like I don't
know I there's something about public
school that I I ended up living in a
house with Cam Girls full of other girls
who'd gone to public school and I don't
know if how much of his genetic or like
just because I'm weird or is it because
of her upbringing but I felt like I was
much more fearless and much more weird
and creative online than other people
were not because they weren't awesome
people but because I think like public
school I got the impression based on
them talking about it it sort of like
beats out any sort of deviance from you
like it more so than your because I I
got the hey we had moral deviants was
beaten out but like you could do
whatever creative deviants wasn't so
much like I didn't have other kids
making fun of me ever I didn't I don't
think I'd ever heard an insult about my
physical appearance as a child or a
teenager once so your father was
basically saying you're not good enough
was intellectual oh no that was like a
moral failure moral failure yeah like I
was not virtuous
wow like in various ways like you know
like you're lazy and mostly the lazy
part because I like I have like ADHD or
something uh yeah and it was I was not
good at it as a kid either I would
totally forget all the time and
is there some sexual repression aspect
to that like uh you know how they say
that there's um it's it's not just
homeschooling but just like Catholic
girls and so on just because like
there's moral you're forbidden to do
certain things like there's a kind of
liberating feeling of saying
like basically rediscovering yourself or
discovering your freedom by doing just
uh diving head in head first into
sexuality into your own sexuality is
there some aspect of that yeah
absolutely to some degree I think that
like people kind of model it slightly
wrong like I think there's a truth to it
but when I first got out of the house
for me Freedom was like going outside at
2AM or like eating chocolate you know on
days that I previously wasn't allowed to
eat chocolate like that was like a
really intense expression of rebellion
for me and I think people like don't
think of this like like I got out a lot
of my like intense Rebellion through
things that people don't typically
consider to be rebellious at all sure
like I wore a bikini yeah insane uh I
just like walked around and then like
I can do this yeah
and so like this was most of that
emotional processing for me um and I
took me a couple years from leaving home
and all of that conservative culture
into doing sex work and in the meantime
I was I did try having sex with a lot of
people but this was mainly because I
didn't know what the Norms were I didn't
really understand I was just like okay
take things logically take things one
step at a time I'm like okay if the
whole previous set about like how I'm
not supposed to kiss somebody until the
altar of marriage if that's not the way
that things were supposed to go then
what is the way things are supposed to
go and I was like well if I am aroused I
should go have sex with someone right is
there any reason not to no so I went I
just I would go around asking random
people to have sex with me did you have
any peer pressure saying like that's not
good or that is good or like any did you
feel any currents of society in any
direction it's probably or are you
independently just thinking like for
from first principles I think I mean
like I'm not saying it was a totally a
clean thing I'm sure that I was
experiencing Society telling me this is
bad but you have to know like I wasn't
watching normal movies when I was a teen
like we watched Christian movies we are
the stuff that we watched was filtered
like I watched the Titanic and I had no
idea that Jack and Rose had sex because
it was put through uh filtered or did
they yeah they went and you know he
painted her naked and yeah yeah there's
a scene in a car
cars and storage and these there's a
hand I watched it again later and I was
like I don't remember the sex scene well
maybe were you also put through uh
maybe it's the filter I see like did the
couple in the notebook also have sex
because maybe for romantic movies I
focus on the romance
maybe right and the sex scenes are
always like weirdly filmed in these yeah
because it's never I mean
it doesn't it feels more like romance
and sex
I guess that's the main focus of this
right yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
anyway so they had sex it's good to know
they did I'll go back and and watch you
have your own effects filter on your
brain and once you realize that there
are some um like the foundation of your
beliefs
were wrong then everything might be
wrong and you're kind of just doing yeah
principles basically and again like not
totally separate from culture but also I
think in general I also have a
predisposition to just be like you know
[__] what culture tells you just figure
out what's right for you and do it and
so that mixed with you know the figuring
things out from first principles I did
eventually figure out that I didn't like
having casual sex with just anybody
quite as much so I stopped that but it
took me a while to figure that out
what's the negative of casual sex it's
just like not good I mean the
you're at the chemistry you have with
someone better then then it can be a lot
nicer but I wasn't doing that I was just
like somebody I met and I'm like you
seem kind of cute okay like I didn't
bother to try and develop just any
chemistry I mean I didn't chemistry even
outside of sex just chemistry like human
chemistry conversation yeah okay I would
I would I'm it's like kind of cringy but
I would like I would like walk up to
guys or send them messages like would
you like to have coitus is what I would
say you would say coitus I said that
I mean it's kind of it's kind of cute in
a way I mean it's a girl asking you to
get laid so they probably didn't care
that much
I'm saying that like I had a lot of
rebellion out of my system by the time I
started sex work yeah
um so like for me like maybe I'm sure it
was somehow related because we were
extremely sexually repressed growing up
I remember the day I learned I had a
vagina which was absolutely horrifying
uh do not recommend figuring out you
have another orifice in your body
um but like do you want to share the
process of you figuring out that you had
a vagina or he told me I had a vagina oh
like intellectually like there was
somebody said you have your vagina
vagina yeah and that was horrifying to
you yeah
I didn't know I had because you weren't
supposed to ever like touch or look at
yourself ever so I never did it was
really disgusting
and so I had no idea that what was going
on in my genital region and so one day
my mom sat me down I think it was like
nine or ten
and she was like you have a
there's another what
and you're going to bleed out of it is
what she told me well you're gonna bleed
out of it for a while and I was like
what the [__] mom
I didn't know the word [__] was but I
would have said that if I had known when
did you first learn the word [__] oh I
think I learned it when I was at a
playground and it was written somewhere
and I read it out loud and then a kid
next to me started giggling uh-huh did
you ever did you say [__] again for a
while no I think the next episode I I
swore the first time I was 18.
like intentionally said a swear word
when I was 18. did you feel good I was
like really nervous I was like nervous
I mean [__] pretty good yeah it [__]
pretty good yeah